[Musica]
ma insomma che cos'è la musica la musica
è la chiave che ne siate consci o meno
siamo tutti esseri musicali che vivono
in un universo musicale tutto è musica
tutto suona anche i gesti quotidiani
mira camminare nuoto musica sport
senti musica anche bere un caffè musica
perché i movimenti necessari per
compiere questo gesto sono concatenati
in una certa sequenza e in un certo
tempo come suonare non parliamo del
mondo esterno uccellini foglie vento
voci alto ma c'è di più
questo è quello che accade a livello
superficiale la musica invece anche
all'interno della materia delle cellule
degli atomi tutto quello che appartiene
al mondo fisico materiale ma anche
spirituale del motivo nasce da un nucleo
sonoro da una struttura intrinsecamente
vibratoria secondo la scienza moderna
attuale ormai assodato che esiste il
campo di vibrazione dinamica che unisce
e sostiene sopra il quale fluttua
l'intera esistenza
quindi l'universo e musica solidificata
ed è in questo mare di frequenza che noi
tutti galleggiamo ma allora
se il nostro corpo viene dalla musica
viviamo in un mondo musicale in un
universo musicale che ruolo deve avere
la musica nelle nostre vite terapeutico
preventivo spirituale curativo oppure
matematico fisico oppure ricreativo di
aggregazione tutti tutti noi oggi però
prenderemo in esame solo un aspetto
quello educativo e il perché lo capiremo
prendendo in prestito due frasi di
platone la prima frase il più importante
e principale a fare pubblico e la buona
educazione della gioventù vela perché lo
capiate meglio la cosa più importante
che devono fare delle persone quando
stanno insieme che sia una famiglia una
nazione è pensare a crescere bene i
propri figli
non aggiungo altro la seconda frase
lasciateci descrivere l'educazione dei
nostri uomini come deve essere quindi
l'educazione forse potremmo trovare
difficilmente qualcosa di meglio di
quanto ha già scoperto l'esperienza del
passato alla quale consiste consiste io
credo nella ginnastica per il corpo e
musica per la mente platone che è
esistito tra il quinto e il quarto
secolo avanti cristo dice che già in
passato avevano scoperto questa cosa che
la musica e la ginnastica erano
fondamentale per i nostri figli per la
crescita dei bambini in ogni epoca
storica ogni protagonista da russo a
socrate quintiliano steiner piagge
montessori tutti quanti convergono nella
stessa idea che sia di fondamentale
importanza dare un'educazione musicale
ai bambini e che non esistono bambini
dotati o meno l'educazione musicale è
importante perché altrimenti cresceremo
degli individui privi di sensibilità non
solo nei confronti della musica ma in
tutto ciò che è espressione e
comunicazione
ma non serve scomodare questi personaggi
illustri per capire che
cosa fondamentale questa siamo stati
tutti i nove mesi più o meno nella
pancia della mamma
note giorno caldo freddo pioggia sole
per nove mesi abbiamo sentito un battito
incessante che ha accompagnato la nostra
crescita
e così assieme ad esso una melodia
eterea ed avvolgente come il respiro
quindi per nove mesi noi abbiamo sentito
questo se poi la mamma era in ritardo e
con la spesa è chiaro che poi quando
siamo venuti al mondo
eravamo dei musicisti esperti la prima
cosa che abbiamo fatto ed emettere un
suono a ogni sollecitazione sonora un
bambino inter bambino interagisce
immediatamente con gioia la scena è
questa e giacomino che a un anno il
pannolone comincia subito a interpretare
a modo suo costo pannolone e tutti
quanti intorno a lui la famiglia bravo
giacomino bar al ballo gioco e giacomino
contento balla fino a che non raggiunge
i 5 6 anni e poi si accorge che a
ballare e solo lui normalmente quindi è
la cultura e il sistema scolastico che
plasmano o insabbiano questa musicofilia
vediamo un attimo a livello scolastico
come è messa il nostro come messo il
nostro sistema educativo
adesso faccio un po il pagliaccio però
non ci vado distante fra martino
campanaro 2 scendi dalle stelle con
bambini pietrificati della paura maestri
isteriche che suggeriscono genitori
annoiati che riprendono uno spettacolo
che non è proprio così allegro
asili nido
ne ho girati in vent'anni centinaia in
tutti si ascoltano le stesse canzoni le
polpette di nonna pina
il coccodrillo fa così come se i bambini
con la loro magia non riuscissero a
percepire ravi shankar o beethoven medie
flauto dolce ma secondo voi con i ritmi
forsennati della nostra società un
flauto dolce può fare innamorare un
bambino della musica io dico prendi una
batteria montata al completo e di chi
vai vedrà se non gli piace
prendi un ampli da 100 watt attaccati un
jackie una chitarra elettrica e di lì
vai bambino vai e lui è chiaro che gli
piace bisogna fare innamorare i bambini
della musica e capire che la musica non
è importante solo tanto quanto la
matematica la storia la geografia ma di
più
musica ginnastica sono le basi è per
questo che negli ultimi vent'anni mi
sono dedicato un progetto di pedagogia
musicale che ha come obiettivo quello di
arrivare a bambini in stato di disagio
il disagio può essere di due tipi un
disagio materiale mancanza de ski un
disagio emotivo playstation
bene dopo questo progetto
l'ho applicato in veneto per vent'anni
circa 80 istituti ne hanno preso parte
20.000 bambini hanno preso parte a
questo progetto
e dopo questa esperienza nella regione
ha deciso di dare una veste
internazionale
e così sono stato a calcutta in india in
togo questa africa e nella repubblica
domenicana
ho il mio obiettivo non è quello di
formare percussionisti per me il mio
obiettivo è quello di piantare un seme
anzi di riscoprire un tesoro che è lì da
sempre per me non è importante che il
bambino sony la chitarra e flauto il
violino o faccia il calzolaio piuttosto
che il medico per me è importante che il
bambino capisca il valore della musica
l'importanza della musica e la sua
valenza universale e quindi questo
progetto che sta portando a livello in
giro a livello internazionale a un
percorso che dura due mesi e mezzo tre e
che sfocia con uno spettacolo finale
in questo spettacolo finale tutti i
bambini fino a 250 in togo in africa
suonano tamburi fatti da loro con
materiale riciclato e decorati da loro
dopodiché inizia la fase della
continuità quando io torno qui prima di
andarmene forma dei gruppi di bambini in
base alla predisposizione individuale
contro gli strumenti inserisco degli
insegnanti locali pago loro delle
mensilità affinché si installino dei
corsi stabili di musica perché questo
perché la musica cambia gli stati
d'animo cambia le persone cambia una
casa cambia un quartiere cambia il mondo
la musica rende liberi come ho detto il
mio filosofo preferito che è bob marley
ho visto nel corso degli anni il più
grande percussionista brasiliano
carlinhos brown costruire nella favela
in cui è nato
una scuola di musica fracat1 ora questa
favela da luogo di degrado è diventata
luogo di turismo di arte di cultura
ho visto a bishek bambino di cinque anni
che ha preso parte al progetto proposto
in india iniziare a parlare tramite la
musica non l'aveva mai fatto prima
ho visto ragazzi disabili feriti nel
corpo nell'anima di un incidente
stradale trovare la voglia di esprimersi
tramite tamburi e la voglia di vivere
ho visto ragazzi destinati a salvador de
bahia ai cartelli della droga venire
formati in scuole di musica per bambini
di strada uscirà 18 anni come musicisti
professionisti e tornare nella stessa
scuola come insegnanti
ho visto decine di bambini di ragazzi
ormai adulti incontrarmi per strada a
salutarmi ringraziandomi del percorso
svolto 25 anni fa di cui conservano un
ricordo vivo e da cui sono partiti per
entrare nel mondo della musica
conclusione come vi lascio cosa vi
portate a casa da tutta questa cosa
una cosa fondamentale ballate cantate e
suonate ascoltate più che potete ogni
giorno perché quando fate queste azioni
siete felici cosa sta cosa stiamo
cercando dalla vita se non la felicità e
non aspettate quella volta al mese
quella volta l'anno per ballare e
cantare perché vi sentite felici
il contrario ballate cantate e suonate
per trovare la felicità
vivete la musica ognuno a modo vostro
perché la musica importante anche in una
sala operatoria o nella costruzione di
un ponte o nell'adattare un bambino o
nel crescere una pianta che voi la
cerchiate o meno o che vi sentiate
particolarmente musicali la musica
esercita sulla totalità di noi un enorme
potere questa musicofilia è lampante fin
dalla nascita e risale agli albori della
nostra specie può essere plasmata dalla
vita dagli eventi dal talento ma è
radicata in noi è innata siamo tutti
creature musicali e quindi è
fondamentale
abbandonarsi a questo meraviglioso
codice che è la musica già rahman
[Applauso]